That number is two one nine two David P..
Here is a good question, but from someone
who sounds maybe a little confused about the
numbers.
Take a listen to this.
Hey, my name is Billy.
I call from middle of New Jersey.
I had a thought about the election.
If you think about all the info and everybody
who's voting, what's the best possible voter?
No count going into this election.
I'm thinking for Joe Biden to win, no matter
what, it's gonna be 120 million votes.
And that would probably leave Donald Trump
to 40 to 50 mil.
That's my thought on him.
Best possible chance of winning no matter
what.
OK.
So listen, you are correctly identifying that
Joe Biden needs a big margin of victory in
the popular vote to safely if you account
for everything, if you account for the way
in which the system is lopsided to help Republicans.
That's the Electoral College system to account
for voter fraud that not not voter suppression,
rather, and election fraud and all of those
other things.
Yes, Joe Biden needs a nice, healthy, popular
vote margin, but 120 million to 40 million
is not going to happen.
That's just not.
First of all, I don't even think that that
many people are going to vote.
Last election, it was both Hillary and and
Trump had in the 60 million range.
I don't remember if it was sixty three to
sixty year, 64 to 62, something like that.
What you're suggesting 120 million to 40 million.
That's like a three to one victory for Joe
Biden.
Joe Biden is not going to win 75 to 25.
Okay.
I think that if you look at the data and Nate
Silver has put this data out, if Joe Biden
can win by four, his chances of winning the
Electoral College are very, very good.
If Joe Biden were to win by five or six in
the popular vote, he would almost certainly
win the Electoral College.
So you're thinking in the right terms, the
numbers are a little bit out there.
But the point is, we need every vote.
We need to run up the score in every state.
Assume nothing.
Concede nothing.
And if we do that, you could have Joe Biden
in the high 60 millions.
And Donald Trump in the low 60 millions.
It is certainly possible.
We have a great bonus show planned for you
today.
Donald Trump's former campaign manager has
been hospitalized.
It's a very sad story, actually.
We're going to talk about it.
There is a cult leader who claims to be the
reincarnation of Jesus.
I've actually seen a documentary about him.
He's been arrested in Russia.
We'll tell you why.
And also, major breaking news on time travel,
although I guess if time travel were possible,
somebody would have already come back and
done the bonus show already.
And you'd know by now.
No, I'm kidding.
But major news about paradox, free time travel,
which I am very much looking forward to discussing
with you on the bonus show.
Get instant access to the bonus show by becoming
a member at join Pacman dot com.
And don't forget, tomorrow night, 8:00 thirty
p.m. Eastern five thirty p.m. Pacific debate
number one between Donald Trump and Joe Biden.